-Piece.
[ Laughter ]
-"P--"
"Piece"...
-Piece!
-It's an awful clue.
It's an awful clue, right?
Other one was so much better!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my goodness,
you're gonna kill me.
-War?
-Whoo!
-That's what I would've guessed.
-Go.
-Rug.
[ Scattered laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
Is that an Aussie term?
-No, no, no.
-Yes, it is!
-Listen, I dunno!
I dunno nothin'!
Vegemite!
-Vegemite!
What? No.
Rug. Rug.
-Toupee.
-Yeah!
♪♪
-Oh, my goodness, the rules of
the game were very simple.
-Simple rules.
-Yes, simple!
-I will give each of you a
password.
-Uh-huh.
-Then each of you are to give
a one-word clue --
that's one word only.
-Mm-hmm.
-Give to your partner
to guess the clue, if the clue's
illegal, as determined by
our judges, you will hear this
sound -- [ Buzzer ]
And you will forfeit your turn.
-Mm-hmm.
-Ah!
-The team with the most points
after four words wins --
any questions?
-Well, I was just wondering --
-That's great.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy and Hugh,
we'll start with you and Hugh.
-I go first.
All right.
-The password is...
"Dolphin."
-Okay, Hugh,
we'll start with you.
This is the "man" team --
Offerman and Jackman.
That's the "on" team --
Fallon and Sarandon.
-If we got married, we'd be
Nick, uh, Jack-Offerman.
-All right, here we go,
one-word clue.
-One-word clue.
-Flipper.
-Mm, dolphin?
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Whoa! Whoa!
Wowee-kazowee!
-♪ Flipper, Flipper! ♪
-Wow!
-♪ Faster than lightning ♪
-Susan.
[ Fallon imitating dolphin ]
-Is that -- is that one word,
or is that hyphenated?
-The password is...
"Oyster."
-Susan, we'll start with you.
-Oh, God!
This is not easy.
-Here we go.
-Oh...
-Wait, wait!
It can't be that hard!
-Yeah, it is.
-Oh, really? Okay.
-Oh, God...
Um...
[ Fallon chuckles ]
-I can get it.
[ Sarandon snickering ]
I can get it, come on, we need
to focus, here we go.
We're focusin',
I can do it.
[ Scattered laughter ]
-Mm!
-No...
-Pearl.
[ Laughter ]
-O-- [ Laughs ]
-Yeah?!
-Oyster!
-Yes!
[ Ding, fanfare,
cheering and applause ]
-Wow!
What a barn-burner!
-Good!
-You and Jimmy!
-I almost said a mollusk!
-The password is...
"Toupee."
-Oh, now it's my turn.
-All right, you ready?
-Oh, God...
Yeah, okay.
-All right, this is a, uh...
'Cause I know if I don't get it,
we're gonna give it to them,
and the next one.
-Yeah, that was what I thought.
-Gosh, I'm so mad.
Okay.
I mean, I'm not really mad.
How can I be made when we're
playing -- okay, ready?
Uh...
-It's okay, it's okay.
It's just a game,
it's okay.
It's okay.
It's all right.
-Piece.
[ Laughter ]
-"P--
"Piece"?!
[ Laughter ]
-Pie-e-ece!
-It's an awful clue.
It's an awful clue, right?
Other one was so much better!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my goodness --
-It's tough!
-You're gonna kill me.
-War?
-Whoo!
-That's what I would've guessed.
-Go.
-Rug.
[ Scattered laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
Is that an Aussie term?
-No, no, no.
-Yes, it is!
-Listen, I dunno!
I dunno nothin'!
Vegemite!
-Vegemite!
What? No.
Rug. Rug.
-Toupee.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging, fanfare,
cheering and applause ]
-That's what I was saying!
I set 'em up!
-I was gonna say
"Charlton Heston."
-Perspicacity.
-Susan and Nick?
-The password is "feather."
-And Nick is gonna begin
on this one.
This is for the win,
it's 11-6.
-But you understand, though,
if I said "rug," we would've
guessed, like, anything else,
you wouldn't have said toupee.
-Is -- is, uh --
-If you'd have gone...
-Is pantomime...?
-No.
-Verboten?
-It's called "Pass word."
-All right, um...
-Don't forget to dumb it down.
-Assuming that I know what
"verboten" means,
I'm gonna say no.
It could easily be verboten.
It could be verboten.
It's a little bit verboten.
-No, it's verboten.
-It's more -- more "perkaspity."
"Pekaspitous."
-Vegemite.
[ Laughter ]
-Quill.
-"Quill"?
[ Audience oohing ]
Snap!
-Wow!
-Damn!
Quill.
-Quill.
Uh...
Pen?
[ Audience groans ]
[ Fallon laughing ]
-Whoo-hoo!
I think so!
-Bird.
-Feather!
-Yeah!
[ Dinging, fanfare,
cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh,
it is a tie!
-We win!
No, it is not!
We won!
Is it a tie?!
It's a tie?!
Then we're gonna have to
have a rematch,
you come back tomorrow night,
I'll see you guys
tomorrow night?
-I'm here tomorrow night anyway!
-Our thanks to Hugh Jackman,
Susan Sarandon, Nick Offerman!
-Wow! Wow!
-Yes! We're ready!
-Let's play some Password!
-Very good, here we good.
-Oh, my God.
Shut the front door.
Well, the rules of the game
are very simple.
-What are they?
-I will give each of you
a password.
Then each of you
are to give a one word clue,
one word only to your partner
to guess the password.
If a clue is determined
illegal by our judges,
you will hear this...
[ Buzzer ]
and you will forfeit your turn.
-Calm down, man.
-I was getting angry.
I get angry when people
don't follow the rules.
-Alright.
-The team with the most points
after six words wins.
Any questions?
-No.
-I was just --
-First clue goes
to Emma and Jim.
-Okay, here we go now.
-Oh, yeah.
-What?
-The password is cruise.
-Emma, why don't you
start us off.
-What?
-You start us off.
-I'm starting, okay.
-Yeah.
Um...
Okay. Oh, no, I don't think
that's quite fair.
Pleasure.
-[ Blows ]
[ Laughter ]
-Sensation?
-Hmm, no.
Leisure.
-Took a conservative guess.
-What?
Say it.
What is it?
What?
[ Laughter ]
-Tom...
-What?
-That's what I was gonna do.
[ Laughter ]
-Tom...
-Hanks?
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Almost.
Down to four points.
-You're such a cheat!
I was gonna to do that.
-You gotta go.
You might win this.
-It wasn't "Hanks"?
-No, it was not -- Hanks
was not the correct answer.
-Tom. Tom.
[ Laughter ]
-You gave me --
-It's not Hanks.
-You can say it again.
You can try it.
-Tom.
-There's pleasure and...
Oh, my...!
Is it obvious?
-It's obvious
if you know it, I guess.
Um, cat?
-Oh, tom cat.
No, no, no.
Down to three points,
three points.
Jimmy Fallon, three points.
-Do I look like an idiot.
-Focus!
-I have.
-Ready?
-Yes.
-Suri.
-Oh!
-What did you say?
[ Laughter ]
Like the voice on the phone,
Siri?
-No, I did not say that.
-No?
Like Suri?
-Suri.
-Like, s...
Tom...
-You better get it, Jim.
-Suri, pleasure.
-No.
-Not pleasure.
-No. Just...
Suri.
[ Laughter ]
-Tom...Jones?
-"Tom Jones"?!
-Jim!
-Emma.
Your turn, two points,
for two points.
-That is ridiculous.
-I really hope I know it.
-I think you know this one.
-I think I got it, yeah.
-He's got it. He's got it.
Just say anything.
-Tom.
-Cruise?
-Thank you.
[ Dinging ]
-Two points!
Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I confused you.
I'm sorry.
-Okay.
-Gosh, sorry.
-The password is nerd.
-I start?
-Michael, you go first.
-Michael's turn.
Michael's gonna go first.
-Geek.
-Computer.
-Oh, so close.
-You're gonna get this.
[ Laughter ]
-You have say something.
One word.
[ Laughter ]
-Sheldon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nerd.
-Yeah.
[ Dinging ]
-Wow!
-Oh, my God, the score.
This is a barn burner,
barn burner.
Third word.
-Third word, here we go.
-Third word.
-The password is sausage.
-I got first?
-You go first.
-Oh, that's fitting.
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
-Oh, we're first.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Bratwurst.
-Sausage.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-We're having a sausage party
over here.
-Alright now,
Michael and Jim.
-The password is sweater.
-Jim, you're going begin.
This one is worth five points.
-They've got 11.
-Okay.
-How do we have 11 points?
-Do they start?
-Points go down.
Somebody explained it
to me backstage.
-It's 36-1.
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Something happened.
-Should you go first?
-Definitely.
-Yeah. I think so, yeah.
-Oh, wait.
-No, go ahead.
Go ahead.
-What?
-You go first.
-I don't want to break
the game or anything.
-I don't know the rules
that well.
-Yeah, we're just making up
as we go.
-Bratwurst, everyone
would have said sausage.
-It was a good one, right?
-You got the point
because you went first.
-Wow. Fine.
-I'm just saying.
I'm just saying.
-Oh, snap.
Hey, alright, alright.
Back to the game.
-A lot of timing in this game.
That's all I'm saying.
-Michael, please.
Back to the game.
Let's see if you can make
the magic happen.
-Keep your people in line,
Thompson.
I'm just saying.
Go on, go on.
-Back off, back off.
-Alright, alright.
-I'm sorry for what I said.
-No, I'm sorry, too.
[ Laughter ]
Just move on there.
Here we go.
One word only.
One word.
-Here we go.
-Angora.
-Oh, well.
Sweater.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's serious
when he goes first.
-Angora.
Alright, here we go.
It's 11-8.
-The password is thong.
-Oh, my gosh.
-No, it's yours.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-I hate that word, so I'm not
going to say that word.
-Okay.
-Undies.
[ Laughter ]
-Panties?
-No.
-That's the word I don't like.
You can't say that word.
It's a gross word.
People don't like
to say that word.
-What word?
-They don't say what he said.
-Panties.
-No, stop saying that.
-I'm going to say it again.
Panties.
No stop saying it.
Undies.
-Undies.
-Bloomers.
-Undies, panties, alright.
-Well, you're giving him
clues now.
-I am. I am.
Just hold that thought.
-Hold that thought.
Hold that thought she said.
That's not cheating, right?
-Okay.
You're holding the thought.
-I got it.
-Painful.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She's acting.
She's acting.
-Hey, hey, hey.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
It's not charades.
-How do you know she was acting
and not just making
an adjustment?
-That's true.
-Painful.
-Thong.
[ Dinging]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is it.
This determines the game.
-I think when they change the
rules, they determined the game.
That's fine, you know?
Whatever.
-The password is pot.
-I just did this.
-Alright, whatever.
Mike can do it.
This has gone to hell
in a hand basket.
-What's your other hand doing?
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here we go.
Now.
Now, Mike, are you
going to start.
-Oh, man. Where do I go
with this.
Oh. Oh, man.
Oh, I'm cracking.
-No, it's good.
It's more than one word though.
-Marijuana.
-Hmm.
-Nice.
-Oh, was that your go?
-Oh, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-That doesn't count.
Judges.
Judges, that doesn't count.
You can do it again.
-We have to cut that.
-Yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait. Weed
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
Let's bring it home!
-Ganja.
-Wait.
-What?
-You didn't -- You thought --
-That confused him.
-How did that make it worse?
-What. What was the first one?
-We had a drum roll
for [bleep]sake.
-Weed.
-Ganja.
Pot.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our winners!
-Oh, it's been
such a pleasure,
such a pleasure.
-Oh, thanks.
-Everybody wins!
-Thank you so much.
Take care, buddy.
-Our thanks to Emma Thompson,
Jim Parsons, Michael Cera.